hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
joe biden continues to daughter around
uh it is
incredible how we are the the democratic
party is now completely reliant
on the continued durability of a man who
clearly
is uh is losing it here was the
president of the united states yesterday
saying that he ran for three reasons but
he can only remember two i remember when
this killed rick perry's presidential
campaign when he did something similar
but apparently it's no problem when
sitting presidents of the united states
can't put things together
when i i said i was running when i
announced my campaign
and not many people took it seriously i
said i was running
for three reasons one to restore the
soul of this country a sense of decency
and honor
but secondly to rebuild the backbone of
the country
hard-working middle-class folks
who built this country okay so um that's
that's great he can't remember
basic things also polls show that joe
biden is in a bit of trouble
as he should be according to a brand new
poll six in 10 americans
say that they blame joe biden for
trouble on inflation
according to mediaite 20 voters said his
economic policies
were somewhat responsible according to
this new study conducted
for political by morning consult another
39 said the policies were very
responsible 12 said they didn't know
only 28 percent of americans
said that joe biden's policies were not
too responsible or not responsible at
all
for the surge in inflation inflation has
continued to surge
the bureau of labor statistics indicated
food prices increased significantly in
the month of june alone
including the cost of beef which is up
4.5 eggs 3.1 percent milk
0.05 home prices have also increased
setting record year-over-year growth of
in may in fact jerome powell who's the
head of the federal reserve he said yeah
by the way you know we were saying that
inflation is transitory and all that
um what we meant was it's not transitory
here's jerome powell
the process of reopening the economy is
unprecedented
as was the shutdown at the onset of the
pandemic
as the reopening continues bottlenecks
hiring difficulties and other
constraints
could continue to limit how quickly
supply can adjust
raising the possibility that inflation
could turn out to be higher
and more persistent than we expect oh
well
no big deal though it's all good
everything's good in fact the new york
times has an entire piece today
about how isn't it magical that when we
just give people money
that we alleviate poverty they have a
big big piece in the new york times by
jason deparle today quote pandemic aid
programs spur a record
drop in poverty the most comprehensive
study yet of the federal response to the
pandemic shows huge
but temporary benefits for the poor and
helps frame a larger debate over the
role of government see here's the thing
according to the left the way you sell
poverty is you just drop bags of cash on
people
according to the right the way that you
solve poverty is you incentivize people
to make better decisions for their
family that allow them to climb the
rungs of success
that's permanent you want to get people
out of poverty you incentivize them to
get jobs you incentivize them to get
educated you incentivize them to make
responsible financial decisions
according to the left
the way that you make people not poor is
you drop
fiat money on them and inflate the
currency and apparently this is supposed
to
by the way there are consequences to
that here is one of the consequences
the brand new q2 gdp growth stats are
out today
they were expected to be 8.5 right
record massive
growth that was the expectation 8.5 8.4
percent the economy instead
grew at a pitiful 6.5 percent
in the last quarter so they only
the economist only missed by 25
there are 400 000 initial jobless claims
that is a huge gdp miss it is a huge
gdp miss and that gdp means
the democrats are going to blame that on
the covet uptech it is not due to the
covetec
it is due to the government botching
covid and it is due to the public health
messaging and
it is due to the fact that you are
paying people to stay home and it is
suppressing
economic growth you're inflating the
currency or inflating prices demand is
starting to decline
because you have inflated the prices and
because productivity is not
ramping up to meet demand all of this
is policy policy is what is doing this
right now if you just left everything
the entire democratic party was going
around shouting build back better we got
to build
you know that's the thing build that you
didn't even build back to regular
when they say build back better what
they mean is what if we used this
pandemic as an excuse to dismantle
all of the institutions of success that
had created a historically prosperous
economy in march of last year what if we
just dismantled all of that and then
built it back better
instead here's what you get you get my
seven-year-old
building a beautiful structure with her
blocks and then my one and a half year
old coming in wrecking it
and then stacking two blocks and being
like i built back better this is what
you have done
if you are the democratic party at this
point that is a
terrible miss 6.5 growth versus 8.5
growth not even close not even close
and this is because of the battery it is
because they've blown money into this
economy at unbelievable record rates
that were unnecessary you know most
people in america
ended the pandemic with more in savings
than they started the pandemic with
that's how much money we spent and joe
biden's plan after that was
instead of telling everybody to get back
to work his plan was
what if we just keep giving you money
like forever and the new york times
they're cheering it on like good little
idiots they are
quote the huge increase in government
aid prompted by the covid pandemic will
cut poverty nearly in half this year
from pre-pandemic levels and pushed the
share of americans in poverty to the
lowest level on record
according to the most comprehensive
analysis yet of a vast but temporary
expansion
of the safety net the number of poor
americans is expected to fall by nearly
20 million from 2018 levels a decline of
almost 45 percent
the country has never cut poverty so
much in such a short period of time
and the development is especially
notable since it defies economic
headwinds
the economy has nearly seven million
fewer jobs than it did before the
pandemic
yes because the way that you solve
poverty according to the left is you
just shovel meaningless dollars at
people
which is not a medium or long-term
solution to poverty
it has never been a medium or long-term
to just shovel money at people it
exacerbates over the long-haul systemic
poverty it it creates incentives for
people to make worse financial decisions
it reduces
growth rates it gets rid of incentive
for entrepreneurs to create new
businesses and better products and
services
the joe biden is going to feel the uh
the burden here he really is
the democratic party has blowback coming
2022 is going to be a very bad year for
them
it's the reason why they're so reliant
on the january 6th commission because
if at any point the american people look
around and realize
that we shouldn't be in a slow growth
mode here we should be in the fastest
growth
probably ever thanks to the artificial
coma the economy was put in last year
and now it's being blown by the
incompetence of a spend
first tax later administration yeah the
american people are not going to react
well to this in any way shape or form
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment